hello everyone i'm here today with mr
benjamin dichter who's the owner
operator of his own rig and
integrally involved with the
organization and ongoing activities of
the truckers convoy in ottawa and so mr
dichter has something to read to us
today which outlines what the truckers
have accomplished and
wanted to accomplish and hope to still
accomplish and i thought this would be a
really good way of informing everyone in
his direct
manner as possible of what the aims of
this protest movement
what what are the aims of this protest
movement so mr dictor thank you for
will being willing to talk to me and
i'll let you uh say anything you want
and also to take it from here
okay thank you jordan and uh so we just
prepared a statement that
can really solidify some of the basics
so nobody's confused so i'm going to
read exactly what our statement is
the freedom convoy is a peaceful and
loving loving demonstration based on the
principles of unity and respect for all
canadians
we have come to ottawa with two very
simple demands
one
the government and all covet mandates
and two the federal government remove
its digital covid tracking app called
arrive can as a requirement to re-enter
canada
we have not anticipated the thirst for
freedom in all canadians after two long
years of restrictions and harsh
lockdowns which in the midst of a in the
minds of a sense of sensible canadians
are not in the spirit
of the charter of rights and freedoms
and our esteemed constitution
the supporters of our convoy have come
from all walks of life
and have been a source of unification
for canadians from across all provinces
and cultures
we are not a group interested in
identity politics or racial divisions
we are in fact open to all people who
want to share their love
and help with the revival of the
canadian identity
the freedom convoy leadership spans the
country and comes from various
indigenous
rural and urban communities
all who have an ambition for unification
and freedom
our demands have not changed from day
one
and the mandates and end the passports
and we'll all go back home to our
communities and our businesses and help
canada heal from the coveteers
there have been many demands attributed
to us
that are not our demands primarily from
the uh legacy media
we do not want to overthrow the
government
we do not want to remove any of our
elected officials from power that's what
elections are for
we do not want to confront we do not
want confrontation with the good people
of law enforcement within our
organization and within our crowds
we have countless first responders and
military veterans who are all proud
of the ottawa police
we do not wish for military action
we want nothing other than for our
peaceful and loving demonstrations
as well as our community outreach to
help inspire our fellow canadians
to have a voice and to appreciate the
freedoms which we are fortunate enough
to have
and which many others in the world
struggle to achieve
we also would ask that our political
class and the legacy media tone down
their rhetoric
the era of slander and indiscriminately
labeling fellow citizens with
pejoratives or as racists needs to come
to an end we need to talk openly and
respect one another but we cannot
achieve this if our political political
class
continues to behave
in such an unparliamentary manner while
the legacy media attacks the very people
they are supposed to reach
the unifying goal that all canadians
have is we want to a return to a normal
life
a free life
no matter where one lies on the
political spectrum
now is the time
and the first courageous step would be
for the federal government to remove
these divisive policies of mandates
and data tracking of our citizens
allow us all to heal together
peace love and unity is the future of
the canadian identity
let's inspire the world to follow us on
this journey of enlightenment
that's all
all right well so that in a nutshell is
what the truckers protest and the
leaders of the truckers protest in
ottawa
do and don't want and that's as clear as
statement as we're likely to
manage and to receive at this point in
time so mr dichter thank you very much
for
your
willingness to share that and for your
forthrightness with me and with your
fellow canadians
no my pleasure my pleasure
all right well we can all pray for peace
and stability and sanity to prevail and
with any luck we'll get the country on
its feet again and get moving forward as
we all should
indeed indeed
you